you
the group's who protest the Danish car
to hoop row tested the Danish cartoons
the threats I think that those are sort
of terrible things but I don't think the
vast majority of the populations we're
talking about and those who are affected
by things like headscarf laws are
involved in that if they are they're
pulled in by the sense of discrimination
and objection they feel in the in the
host countries in which in which they
live but more than that I don't see how
banning headscarves makes any difference
in the reaction of politicized Islamic
groups to something like the Danish
cartoons it seems to me that the the Q
are being offered doesn't fit the
problem that's being defined and the
cure is a kind of general Islamophobia
that attaches to all Muslims and that
affects the practices of all Muslims so
I think it's girls in head scarves are
benign I really don't think that that is
the flag of Islamic terrorism or the the
cover for deeply felt terrorist
inclinations I do think for theirs their
issues of religious belief there are
issues of identification with a world
movement that removes you from the kind
of more objective ethnic racial
inferiority you feel in the country that
you are so that you can you can identify
with something that's bigger than you
and that feels more comfortable or it
gives you a kind of recognition that
you're otherwise feel feel you're not
getting so I you know there are lots of
issues involved in the choice to wear a
headscarf but I don't think wearing a
headscarf or having people not wear head
scarves or not wear burkas has anything
to do with addressing the problem of
political action political censorship of
things like the Danish cartoons
I guess I'm you know I'm certainly for
free expression I think that that and I
was the head of the Committee on
academic freedom and tenure at the
American Association of University
Professors though that was the hat I
wore for a long time and I certainly
think free expression is what there
should be there are always tricky
contexts and the the one in which the
Danish cartoons somehow seemed to be a
blow a horrible blow at religious belief
and religious you know if the Danish
cartoons had been swastikas what would
the response have been on the part of
Jewish community I mean maybe people
wouldn't have threatened the lives of
the cartoonists but I think there would
have been outpouring of objection on the
part of members of the Jewish community
about this travesty that was allowed to
be expressed even as freedom of speech
is something that's that's recognized
and you know allowed the Nazi March and
skokie illinois in the in the 1970s or
80s I mean civil libertarians here I
said that March had to be allowed to
take place but so I think I think one
can understand of insensitivity that was
involved in the publication of the
cartoons in a context in which this was
a really volatile and explosive issue
but I think they should have been
allowed to be published I do think
though that as I say I don't think if
they had been I don't think the editors
of the paper would have allowed the
publication of similar cartoons in which
anti-semitism could be the accusation
rather than a tax on on Muslims
no I think I think this I think that was
that was fine i mean i think that and i
think people are looking to sir there
was there were certainly threats and all
of the rest of it but I you know no i
don't i think that can be allowed again
I guess my test always is if if we're as
tolerant of what could be taken to be a
post-holocaust what are taken to be
anti-semitic gestures as anti-muslim
ones then you know I think yeah why not
allow this these characters to sort of
play around and be satirical